when I waltzed off to high school with
my new Nokia phone I thought I just had
the new coolest replacement for my old
pink princess walkie talkie except now
my friends and I could text or talk to
each other wherever we were instead of
pretending when we were running around
each other's backyards now be honest
back then I didn't think a lot about how
these devices were made they tended to
show up on Christmas morning so maybe
they were made by the elves in Santa's
workshop let me ask you a question
who do you think the real elves that
make these devices are if I ask a lot of
the people I know they would say it's
the hoodie wearing software engineers in
Silicon Valley hacking away at code but
a lot has to happen to these devices
before they're ready for any kind of
code these devices start at the atomic
level so if you ask me the real elves
are the chemists that's right I said the
chemists chemistry is the hero of
electronic communications and my goal
today is to convince you to agree with
me okay let's start simple and take a
look inside these insanely addictive
devices because without chemistry what
is an information superhighway that we
love would just be a really expensive
shiny paperweight chemistry enables all
of these layers let's start at the
display how do you think we get those
bright vivid colors that we love so much
well I'll tell you there's organic
polymers embedded within the display
that can take electricity and turn it
into the blue red and green that we
enjoy in our pictures what if we move
down to the battery now there's some
intense research how do we take the
chemical principles of traditional
batteries
and pair it with new high surface area
electrodes so we could pack more charge
in a smaller footprint of space so that
we could power our devices all day long
while we're taking selfies without
having to recharge our batteries or sit
tethered to an electrical outlet what if
we go to the adhesives that binds it all
together so that they could withstand
our frequent usage after all as a
millennial I have to take my phone out
at least 200 times a day to check it and
in the process drop it two to three
times but what are the real brains of
these devices what makes them work the
way that we love them so much well that
all has to do with electrical components
and circuitry that are tethered to a
printed circuit board or maybe you
prefer a biological metaphor the
motherboard you might have heard of that
now the printed circuit board doesn't
really get talked about a lot and I'll
be honest I don't know why that is maybe
it's because it's the least sexy layer
and it's hidden beneath all of those
other sleek looking layers but it's time
to finally give this Clark Kent layer
the Superman worthy praise it deserves
and so I ask you a question what do you
think a printed circuit board is well
consider a metaphor think about the city
that you live in give all of these
points of interest that you want to get
to your home your work restaurants a
couple of Starbucks on every block and
so we build roads that connect them all
together that's what a printed circuit
board is except instead of having things
like restaurants we have transistors on
chips capacitors resistors all of these
electrical components that need to find
a way to talk to each other and so what
are our roads
well we build tiny copper wires so the
next question is how do we make these
tiny copper wires they're really small
could it be that we go to the hardware
store pick up a spool of copper wire get
some wire cutters a little clip clip sew
it all up and then back
we have our printed circuit board no way
these wires are way too small for that
and so we have to rely on our friend
chemistry now the chemical process to
make these tiny copper wires is
seemingly simple we start with a
solution of positively charged copper
spheres we then add to it an insulating
printed circuit board and we feed those
positively charged spheres negatively
charged electrons by adding formaldehyde
to the mix so you might remember from
aldehyde really distinct odor used to
preserve frogs in biology class well it
turns out it could do a lot more than
just that and it's a really key
component to making these tiny copper
wires you see the electrons on from
aldehyde have a drive they want to jump
over to those positively charged copper
spheres and that's all because of a
process known as redox chemistry and
when that happens we can take these
positively charged copper spheres and
turn them into bright shiny metallic and
conductive copper and once we have
conductive copper now we're cooking with
gas and we can get all of those
electrical components to talk to each
other so thank you once again to
chemistry and let's take a thought and
think about how far we've come with
chemistry clearly in electronic
communications size matters so let's
think about how we can shrink down our
devices so that we can go from our 1990s
Zack Morris cell phone to something a
little bit more sleek like the phones of
today that can fit in our pockets
although let's be real here absolutely
nothing can fit into ladies pants
pockets if you can find a pair of pants
that has pockets and I don't think
chemistry can help us with that problem
but more important than shrinking the
actual device how do we shrink the
circuitry inside of it and shrink it by
a hundred times so that we can take the
circuitry from the micron scale all the
way down to the Nano
erskyll because let's face it right now
we all want more powerful and faster
phones well more power and faster
requires more circuitry so how do we do
this it's not like we have some magic
electromagnetic shrink-ray like
professor wayne szalinski used in Honey
I Shrunk the kids to shrink his children
on accident of course or do we well
actually in the field there's a process
that's pretty similar to that and its
name is photolithography in
photolithography we take electromagnetic
radiation or what we tend to call light
and we use it to shrink down some of
that circuitry so that we could cram
more of it into a really small space now
how does this work
well we start with a substrate that has
a light-sensitive film on it
we then cover it with a mask that has a
pattern on top of it of fine lines and
features that are going to make the
phone work the way that we want it to we
then expose a bright light and shine it
through this mask which creates a shadow
of that pattern on the surface now
anywhere that the light can get through
the mask it's going to cause a chemical
reaction to occur and that's going to
burn the image of that pattern into the
substrate so the question you're
probably asking is how do we go from a
burned image to clean fine lines and
features and for that we have to use a
chemical solution called the developer
now the developer is special what it can
do is take all of the non exposed areas
and remove them selectively leaving
behind clean fine lines and features and
making our miniaturized devices work so
we've used chemistry now to build up our
devices and we've used it to shrink down
our devices so I've probably convinced
you that chemistry is the true hero and
we could wrap it up there hold on we're
not done not so fast because we're all
human and as a human I always want more
and so now I want to think about how to
use chemistry to extract
more out of the device right now we're
being told that we want something called
5g or the promised fifth generation of
wireless now you might have heard of 5g
in commercials that are starting to
appear or maybe some of you even
experienced it in the 2018 Winter
Olympics what I'm most excited about for
5g is that when I'm late running out of
the house to catch a plane I can
download movies onto my device in 40
seconds as opposed to 40 minutes but
once true 5g is here it's going to be a
lot more than how many movies we can put
on our device so the question is why is
true 5g not here and I'll let you in on
a little secret it's pretty easy to
answer it's just plain hard to do you
see if you use those traditional
materials in copper to build 5g devices
the signal can't make it to its final
destination traditionally we use really
rough insulating layers to support
copper wires think about velcro
fasteners
it's the roughness of the two pieces
that make them stick together that's
pretty important if you want to have a
device that's going to last longer than
it takes you to rip it out of the box
and start installing all of your apps on
it but this roughness causes a problem
you see at the high speeds for 5g the
signal has to travel close to that
roughness and it makes it get lost
before it reaches its final destination
think about a mountain range and you
have a complex system of roads that goes
up and over it and you're trying to get
to the other side don't you agree with
me that it would probably take a really
long time and you would probably get
lost if you had to go up and down all of
the mountains as opposed to if you just
drilled a flat tunnel that could go
straight on through well it's the same
thing in our 5g devices if we could
remove this roughness then we can send
the 5g signal straight on through
uninterrupted sounds pretty good right
but hold on
didn't I just tell you that we needed
that roughness to keep the device
together and if we remove it we're in a
situation where now the copper isn't
going to stick to that underlying
substrate think about building a house
of Lego blocks we'll all the nooks and
crannies that latch together as opposed
to smooth building blocks which of the
two is going to have more structural
integrity when the 2 year old comes
ripping through the living room trying
to play Godzilla and knock everything
down but what if we put glue on those
smooth blocks and that's what the
industry is waiting for they're waiting
for the chemists to design new smooth
surfaces with increased inherent
adhesion for some of those copper wires
and when we solved this problem and we
will solve the problem and we'll work
with physicists and engineers to solve
all of the challenges of 5j well then
the number of applications is going to
skyrocket so yeah we'll have things like
self-driving cars because now our data
networks can handle the speeds and the
amount of information required to make
that work but let's start to use
imagination
I could imagine going into a restaurant
with a friend that has a peanut allergy
taking out my phone waving it over the
food and having the food tell us a
really important answer to a question
deadly or safe to consume or maybe our
devices will get so good at processing
information about us that they'll become
like our personal trainers and they'll
know the most efficient way for us to
burn calories I know come November when
I'm trying to burn off some of these
pregnancy pounds I would love a device
that could tell me how to do that I
really don't know another way of saying
it except chemistry is just cool and it
enables all of these electronic devices
so the next time you send a text or take
a selfie think about all of those atoms
that are hard at work and the innovation
that came before them who knows maybe
even some of you listening to this talk
perhaps even on your mobile device will
decide that you too want
sidekick to captain chemistry the true
hero of electronic devices thank you for
your attention
and thank you chemistry
[Applause]